hello everyone and welcome to round
three of Qatar Masters yesterday we had
one of the greatest games played in I
don't know how long because it's a
classical game and alisher suan of
grandmas from Kazakhstan defeated Magnus
Carlson in the greatest possible style
if you haven't seen it do check it out
it's my previous video and now another
day Magnus fa faces another
International Master this time Grand uh
no International master mutaya from
India and uh well let's see how Magnus
recuperates after losing a classical
game and can he can he do something in
this one with the white pieces so he uh
opted for E4 with have E5 by mutaya
Knight to F3 Knight to F6 he went for
the uh Petro defense and Magnus goes for
Knight captures on E5 the main line uh
D6 chasing away the Knight Knight to F3
and Knight captures on e4 the classical
variation D3 Knight to F6 and now Pawn
to D4 we have G6 uh and now Bishop to D3
so this is a somewhat rarer with the G6
than uh just advancing the pawn to D5
but also there are some games Bishop G7
both players castle and Here pawn to H3
and there are some games where C5 and
Knight to C6 were played but here we
have Pawn to B6 and it is now as of move
nine that we have a completely new game
so of course uh mutaya wants the F his
light Square bishop and put it on this
long diagonal we have Pawn to C4 by
Magnus Bishop to B7 and n Knight to C3
we have Rook to E8 and now Bishop to E3
uh Knight B to D7 and now Rook to E1 we
have Pawn to H6 and now Pawn to D5 so
Magnus makes the first um change in the
position he advances the pawn to D5
grabs more square squares here the
Knight might have some uh D4 ideas or
maybe even C6 in the future but he also
gives up the C5 Square for mut's Knight
so he goes Knight to C5 uh Bishop to C2
and Now Pawn to C6 uh challenging
magnus's strong Center we have Queen to
D2 putting pressure on the H6 pawn and
here we have a really a very nice uh uh
capture Fest D captures on D5 C captures
on D5 and now Knight F to E4 attacking
the queen on D2 so Magnus trades on e4
again the queen is attacked the bishop
captures on e4 Rook captures and Bishop
captures on H6 so Magnus wins a pawn but
he will also have to give back the D5
Pawn so Rook captures on E1 Rook
captures on E1 or you could capture with
the queen uh but um that that doesn't
really work as then Bishop captures on
H6 happens so Rook captures on E1 Bishop
captures on H6 Queen captures and now
Bishop captures on D5 so some six moves
of pure capturing and now we have this
position where it's magnus's Knight
against the mut bishop and it's uh five
Pawn each two Pawn islands for Magnus
and three Pawn islands for muta and um
okay two Pawn islands are are is pretty
much always better than three Pawn
Islands but here it's uh the the the
past D pawn and you do have the bishop
to help with the advancement of the pawn
so it's okay to be both white and black
here uh we have Knight to D4 Magnus
needs to move the bishop if he wants to
play something like this and try to
organize an attack against the D6 Pawn
of course mut just trades here and then
it's really really hard to prove
anything here uh the the the pass Pawn
might even be a strength here so Bishop
captures on D5 Knights to D4 of course
you have to avoid the trade and now you
can't really capture on A2 it's a poison
Pawn it's as poison as they come so if
you capture here then Knight to C6
attacks the queen and Knight D7 check
ends the game there is no uh defense
against this whatever you do you play
Queen F6 Knight E7 check no squares for
the black king you will have to give up
your queen so instead uh Queen to F6 is
played now putting pressure on the
Knight here and queen back to D2
defending the Knight but the pawn is
still poison not for the reason that
we've just explained but the bishop will
be trapped after B3 and after A5 you
cannot capture it with the queen as the
queen on F6 is attacking the Knight here
but you will go after it with the rook
and now after Bishop captures on B3
Knight captures and defends The Rook on
A1 and it doesn't matter if you play A4
uh because a captures on B3 is not a
threat as The Rook on A8 would hang so
and that's the idea behind why Bishop
captures an A2 does not work now but
Rook to see 8 and now uh Bishop captures
on A2 has become a threat so Magnus
plays Pawn to A3 we have Pawn to A6 and
now Rook to E3 we have King to G7 and
now Knight to E2 uh okay Bishop to C4 uh
clearing the the path for the pass D
Pawn to be pushed forward uh Knight to
G3 we have Pawn to D5 stopping the
knight from coming to E4 and pawn to B3
now here you could also maybe decide to
go for Rook to F3 attack the queen first
because after B3 and Bishop B5 now if
you play Rook to F3 you also have to
worry about Queen to A1 check which was
impossible with the pawn on B2 uh but
still you could play it uh to give you a
fun line if Rook F3 Queen A1 check and
King to H2 you still cannot touch the
pawn this is uh truly a poison Pawn
because now Knight H5 check and black
resigns there's no escaping if you go
King side then Rook captures on F7 if
you go Queen side then Queen to H6 will
end the game and of course if you
capture the Knight then Queen to D4
check King to G G8 and now Queen to F6
of course with the idea of Queen
captures an F7 and once you defend that
just Rook to G3 check King to H7 and
queen to G7 Checkmate this is only one
of the lines but all of them end really
bad for black so while you can play itth
you cannot go after the pawn so maybe
your queen is better suited on on F6 so
here we have uh Pawn to A4 uh and now
Bishop to D7 Knight to E2 Magnus has to
figure out how to properly position the
Knight the D4 square is very very nice
as it's a dark Square your opponent has
a light Square Bishop so the Knight will
be very strong here however you don't
expect to win a game with Knight on D4
we all know that to win games the Knight
has to go to E5 okay Bishop to E6 we
have Knight to D4 and now Pawn to A5 we
have King to H2 and now Queen to F4 with
check Pawn to G3 Magnus weakens his King
side a little bit but it is necessary if
he wants to continue the game Queen to
F6 and now King to G2 uh we have Bishop
to D7 now even Pawn to G4 uh Rook to E8
offering a rook trade and Magnus goes
for it Rook captures on E8 Bishop
captures on E8 and now Queen to E3 and
uh how do you how do you defend here
Bishop to D7 was played but now Knight
to F3 and uh it looks a bit dangerous to
allow the the bishop to come to this
diagonal but uh Magnus has it all worked
out Bishop to C6 and now of course he
cannot go after the B6 Pawn if he
captures the B6 Pawn H then just Pawn to
D4 and he can resign there's no defense
here uh you you cannot uh defend the
knight uh and on the other hand if he
goes something like Knight to E5 which
is the square that you want to bring the
Knight to then D4 check again wins the
game as you hang your your queen here so
what he can do is play Pawn to G5 attack
the black queen and once the queen moves
now play Queen captures on B6 so that's
now now it's uh very much different
because after Pawn to D4 he just plays
King to F1 this was the key move to find
you can now unpin because then now it's
the black queen that is hanging so we
have King to G8 uh Queen captures on D4
Magnus grabs another pawn and now Queen
to E6 here interestingly Queen to E7 is
still a draw when I say A draw it is
possible to hold this with the absolute
best moves because now you prevent the
knight from going anywhere as the G5
Pawn would be lost to give an example if
Knight A5 Queen captures on G5 and knife
Knight captures on C6 there's Queen to
C1 check picking up the Knight so you
cannot really uh activate the Knight
even by uh giving up the G5 Pawn but
after Queen to E6 going after the H3
Pawn which seems like a better idea for
black uh Magnus just plays Knight to E5
and he shows that nope this is not a
good idea for black so now you've
committed you have to go for it mut go
Queen captures on H3 King to E1 and now
Queen to H1 with check King D2 and
Bishop to F3 going after Queen to D1 but
now the position is completely winning
for Magnus if you guys can help him win
it he needs one move feel free to pause
the video and try to find the absolute
best move while I give you a couple of
[Music]
seconds so uh for those of you who were
able to do it congratulations on uh
finding uh all the all the correct moves
with the King you have to calculate
Queen to D1 properly and for those of
you who just want to enjoy the show it
is Queen to Ace I am only joking it is
of course Knight to D7 that's the move
that Magnus played and now the position
is completely winning point being that
after Queen to D1 check which was played
in The Game King to E3 uh you can't
really trade Queens Queen to E2 check
doesn't help if you go King to F4 now uh
what do you do there are no checks uh
Knight to F6 check is coming also the
queen can't really move with the bishop
being here and if you play Bishop to B7
just Queen to E3 and now the king and
pawn end game is winning and also uh the
this Pawn is on a dark Square so if you
even if you go into a knight versus
Bishop the Knight Will very easily
outmaneuver the bishop capture on A5 and
then the the Queens side pawns are
winning so this is out of the question
another thing of course after King D3 uh
you could capture the queen but it's
same thing King captures and you just
gobble up this pawn and easily win the
game uh so after King to E3 Queen
captures on B3 was played but now King
to F4 and again the queen cannot move
the bishop uh here is a problem and if
you go for Queen to D1 now Queen to D1
is sort of the maybe most resilient way
for black to play this there's Knight to
F6 check and after King to f8 Queen to
E5 threatening Checkmate and that's it
uh you either get checkmated with Queen
to E8 Queen to G8 uh Checkmate or you
you move the King deliver some check and
you lose the bishop or if you try to
save the bishop and prevent Checkmate
then it's a matter of Queen to B8 check
and after King to E7 now Queen to C7
check you block with the bishop but now
you just trade everything captures
captures captures and captures and after
King to E5 uh it's equal material but of
course completely winning as the white
king is too active King E7 you get
opposition but now King D5 and you will
uh simply gobble up this pawn and win
the game uh so after Bishop to f after
King to F4 Bishop to C6 was played but
now Magnus just has a forced Checkmate
in seven H which he plays and of course
you guys see it as well as we have the
queen and the Knight ready to jump to F6
don't Knight to F6 check King to G7 and
Knight to H5 delivering a double check
so any Knight King H7 or King to G8 will
be met with Queen to G7 Checkmate so
King to f8 but now Queen to D6 check and
uh now of course if you go here then
it's checkmate with Knight to G7 you
don't have to take the bishop uh so King
to G8 was played but now just Queen to
d8 with check and he was in this
position un move 53 that mutaya resigned
the game as there is nothing more to be
done here uh two more moves will be
played of course if you don't want to
play a silly move like Bishop to E8 so
King to H7 and now of course Knight to
F6 check only move King to G7 and queen
to G8 will be Checkmate so Magnus
bounces back he he he grabs a full point
against muta and magnus's um nemesis
from the previous round alisher sanov
also lost his game today so we're not
going to have um I thought it' be really
cool if he just you know Crush Magnus
and then he ends up winning the
tournament but even though that might
still happen it will not be be as clean
as you know some of you thought that uh
it would be and if you guys are
interested in some other results from
this round uh I don't think all the
games have finished but some of them
have so I'm going to spoil it a little
bit now so Magnus W on board one vov
Drew Nakamura on board two Anish giri
Drew adamal on board three then Arjun
defeated rasulov on board four synov
defeated kaidanov on board five and Nar
defeated sanov yeah we already said that
unboard six and so on and so on So
currently uh there are five players on
100% on full three points it's arjuni
jaok synov narad yab and Robi Kish so
those are the top five currently uh with
with one on 100% then Hikaru on 2 and a
half out of three and so on and so on uh
so yeah that's the game I hope you guys
enjoyed it nicely bouncing back two
games in a row against an international
Master not in you know in you know in
everyday occurrence for Magnus Carlson
but if you lose the game you have to uh
fight your way back to the top uh so
yeah once again hope you guys enjoyed it
I would like to thank no need to mention
me in the video miras 3 Pat Nathan
Gibson nagarjuna porot and David William
grasberger for contribution to my
channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check to
my previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing to check up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the Chess World uh so thank you all I
will see you soon and have an excellent
rest of your day and you still have a
chance to PL Ina f
everything you need to know is in the
link in the description below first
thing you will see see you soon